this week our school matters series is
looking at the issues children parents
and educators face as kids go back to
school for the second time during this
pandemic a new cbs news poll finds 69
percent of parents are concerned their
children will get coveted in school
cases are skyrocketing among kids 12 to
17 up almost 1400 percent since june
only on cbs this morning meg oliver
visited a new york city school with
secretary of education miguel cardona to
learn about his plans for a safe school
year meg good morning anthony good
morning just last week president biden
gave full authority to secretary cardona
to take any action necessary against
states that ban mask mandates in schools
cardona tells me his message is clear we
need to reopen schools not only for kids
education but also for their mental
health
you know it's going to help everyone
mentally because like you can actually
have people to talk to relate to new
friends teachers help you
like most kids jeremy augusto and nana
akwanin want to go back to school when i
was in school
i felt safe i felt
like i was actually learning something
both are vaccinated and play on the
football team at harry truman high
school in the bronx secretary of
education miguel cardona recently
visited their school to talk with
student athletes about a safe return to
the classroom and the field we need our
student leaders to say
don't be the reason you cancel my season
we know students learn best in the
classroom
we know that for their
not only their academic needs but their
social and emotional well-being they
belong in the classroom is it safe to
open full-time with the delta variant
you know as a father i wouldn't send my
children in if i didn't feel they were
safe i wouldn't ask anyone to do
something that i wouldn't do for my own
children my children are going back to
school my children are getting on the
soccer field my children are getting on
that volleyball court because i know as
a father
that their mental health depends on
their ability to engage in that
community and i'm fortunate that my
children are of the age where they can
get vaccinated and i know some parents
will say well my children don't have the
vaccine
but the reality is if we follow the
mitigation strategies we can keep our
children safe much of the concern coming
from parents is the alarming rise of
infections in kids according to the
american academy of pediatrics in just
three weeks the number of coveted cases
and children nearly tripled though
hospitalization rates remain low at only
2 percent and deaths are rare with less
than .03 percent of cases involving kids
how do you reassure the parents who are
scared
i think that's an ongoing
job for educators across the country i
recognize that fear and i experience
that fear as a parent but if our schools
are open and honest with parents and
take the questions that they have and
allay their fears and even show them
examples of it give them tours of the
school parents will see that their
children can be safe the issue of
vaccines is also a safety factor when it
comes to the kids a little over 54
percent of 16 to 17 year olds have
received one dose of the vaccine and
among 12 to 15 year olds that number is
45 percent the lowest vaccination rate
for any age group
should there be a vaccine mandate for
teachers and students you know i know
that vaccines work and i know that
across the country 90 of the educators
have gotten vaccinated i would support
it as you know i don't have that
authority to mandate vaccines but what i
can tell you is in those places where
they're relaxed about it
we have hospitals that are overrun in
those places where they are getting
vaccinated we're able to function more
normally
the football team at harry truman all
planned to be fully vaccinated when
school reopens in september
one main reason i got my vaccine was to
be like a role model
for my other teammates
because i know some of them are like
hesitant their head coach john shepard
says students return to school is
critical
somewhere maybe around a third of our
student athletes
i would say we're at danger for slipping
through the cracks and so you've been
spending your summer calling homes and
trying to get them to come back yeah
when all the circumstances align and a
student can return safely to
participating in you know all the things
that they love doing it's just great to
be able to be a part of it part of the
safe return to school comes with a
recommendation from the cdc that all
students and staff wear masks and just
last week president biden ordered
secretary cardona to take action
including possible legal action against
governors who ban masking in public
schools
we're not going to sit by as governors
try to block and intimidate educators
protecting our children it saddens me to
think that poor policies and political
agendas are going to get in the way of
those kids getting on the field
we need to follow the mitigation
strategies that we know work get the
politics out of this let the education
leaders do their jobs to be very honest
with you i wish we didn't have to wear
masks i know my own children they don't
want to wear masks
i have mask fatigue myself but if it
means giving my children an opportunity
to be in school i'm for it
mask mandates in schools is a volatile
issue a cbs news poll found 36 percent
of parents believe mass should be
optional for any state planning to defy
mass requirements cardona says the biden
administration is prepared to
investigate through the office for civil
rights eight states have banned mass
mandates altogether
the secretary raises a good point nobody
wants to wear a mask i don't know
anybody who enjoys wearing it you know
you you start drooling in there your
glasses fog up it's just it's an
uncomfortable situation but you also
want to live yeah want we saw those
numbers at the tennessee school earlier
in the show where you had a huge number
of percentage of teachers and kids who
are now infected i can't i mean you
can't believe we're going through this
all over again how many ways do we have
to learn what we need to do and speaking
of learning as you open the piece kids
learn best in the classroom yes it's
back there yes i can get my three kids
in the classroom after a year and a half
of all remote they can wear a mask meg i
remember the story you did when we first
started with your three kids and we had
asked about it at the time we thought
this was so funny and it's not going to
last so long
it's bad
year two is even worse